what's one thing to be sitting here with
Little Big Town but we are in the Apollo
Theater that's crazy for me to be yeah
that's like for you guys to be in the
policy to performing the Apollo Theater
hungriest I'm a famous Apollo Theater
and we did we rub the tree stump that's
amazing couple nights ago was the carnie
Carnegie Hall yeah so what's it like to
be playing in these type of venues like
you guys have been doing this for a long
time but it must be special to be in
these kind of type of venues
yeah they're magical you know that's
we've been looking forward to this tour
for that very reason these kinds of
rooms they just provide the vibe and so
it's going to be a lot of fun and these
this weekend has been amazing playing
the new songs and this setting and men
so cool you feel it yeah it's yeah it's
just cool is it one of those things like
a time where you go this is a moment
yeah Carnegie was overwhelming when the
just from the first note of the show you
know it's like you're like about to jump
off a cliff
yeah and such a regal glorious place and
and then here same thing only it has a
different energy it's like yeah all this
history and it feels spiritual and like
I don't know you know it was a different
feeling and the energy was through the
roof and it's just amazing yeah it's not
lost on us for sure
now playing these new songs so we're
both 40 hours since the album has come
on so how you guys feeling better like I
saw Halsey post the video yesterday she
released her album as well she was just
so nervous to put this album there
almost in tears like how are you guys
feeling about putting it out there yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've been you know we've
had it finished for a while now we've I
don't know that we've ever sat this long
with it finished and then just waiting
on the
launched but have we finished it in
August I guess yeah yeah
and so we've we've been ready I
understand her nerves though it is it's
overwhelming because you spent so much
time and energy like producing and
writing and making sure the sequence is
right and the visuals are right and then
all of a sudden you write I thought
there's a piece of yeah yeah isn't weird
to count it give it up like these saying
since it's done in August do you
second-guess things a little bit like
should we go back and we do that enough
we didn't do that as much we're so proud
of it and so ready for people to hear it
and it's been beautiful to response so
far just what we've been able to read
and people's you know reaction to the
music has been amazing yeah and you said
this album is about clarity yeah what
does that mean yeah I mean there's a lot
of questions and in this record and then
I think it's it's clarity just because
we were very intentional about what we
were gonna say so you know from songs
like problem child to the daughters to
sugarcoat I mean everything not for
everyone I know
yeah the way it all flows has messages
but it feels really relevant for what's
going on in the world so what are you
saying on this out thing that we see you
like in your struggle we feel we know
that thing yeah what you're going
through there is hope yeah there's
always hope we did that these days it's
gonna be okay yeah and you've kind of
already got the seal of approval with
another Grammy nominee the Dodgers which
is amazing number 13 I think I counted
right am i right
Grammy's it's always highest honor yeah
like what I know like obviously you guys
have won a lot of awards is there
something different about a Grammy sorry
being recognized by peers like all the
producers and the writers and and that
is in all of music just knowing that
you're getting recognized by them is a
real that's just creatively very
satisfying feeling yeah yeah but this
song the daughters I can own as a few
songs that are about raising kids but
this seems like the pinnacle of that
that song so what do you want to see
with that song specifically just to do
better for the next generation of girls
and that we're still talking about you
know things being equal and equal play
equal pay I mean so many things and that
we grew up with those standards of
always having to look like we have it
all together and we just want to know we
want the younger girls that are coming
up to know that we're fighting for them
and we see them and and we're gonna
champion them ya know did you see that
tweet that got Kelsea Ballerini Kacey
Musgraves like a Michigan radio station
yes now let me play two females back to
back and said they came to play Little
Big Town or Lady Antebellum against
another female like were you shocked I
know like obviously we've been talking
to this room you know years but the lack
of females but you shocked that there's
actually mandates like that I was
shocked yeah I was not shocked by that
but I was shocked that somebody with the
state of where it's at it's it's not
healthy that's not where it should be in
that you know insight into the condition
of where it's Anna's it should be
healthier we should have a great balance
of male female because everyone has
great stories to tell and there's so
much great music being made by females
that we're not hearing right so it's
just you know it is an inside
how I guess behind-the-scene yeah it's
not good we are the parents of daughters
and you know right now if if their girls
were listening to nothing of a country
radio then they would never hear a
girl's story but and so we grew up
loving having faith in Martina and the
Judds and Dolly and Tammie and Loretta
and Tricia and yeah and they they gave
us anthems for our lives so we're really
taking it's very narrow thinking to not
let younger girls and I mean don't you
guys like listening to girls really
sherman and we know the music that's out
there that's not being heard they're our
friends and it's it's incredible
reasonable music yeah it's that it
doesn't research as the excuse that we
get all the time but it doesn't research
because if you don't play something it
won't research very very okay now I love
like the ballads on this album but I
love a good little big town drinking
song yeah literally that was birthed out
of we were writing a very serious song
that day on the road with Topher Brown
and Sean McConnell and yeah and so we
needed a some levity right and we took a
little break really okay guys it's time
for a drink you want a drink we have
wine we have beer we have whiskey and
then I think it was tougher it was like
yeah I mean it's that it's not our most
profound
it's really fun it was fun to think of
all the names it's very close you guys
each have a favorite drink oh I'm a wine
the song a lot of bit of chrome we're
personally keeping that company business
I like wine we have our own wine did you
know we have a sophisticated bottled
wine and then we have a little canned
spritzer called a drinkin can they get
it in Canada we can get it in in select
place yes it's called the spritzers are
really fun and they're called day
drinking the other ones called for
sellers so well Cindy sounds good of
course there's over drinking as well and
then sugarcoats yeah over drinking guts
michelle monaghan in the music video
sugarcoats got Kate Bosworth how did
that come about those two we just were
brainstorming about what actors could we
get and we needed like very classic
sophisticated women and for both of
these videos and we only said two names
rule and those are the two names and
they happened we met but we had just met
them yeah at the CMT Awards okay so we
just reached out to our people called
their people and they said yes and yeah
[Laughter]
they're so delightful their embodied
these characters in these videos so
beautifully so it really tells the story
of these songs yeah and you guys like
the sugarcoat video you're not really in
very much like usually we're gonna be in
all right we cut our Oh
we're like take us out it's too good
yeah you know they're heard portraying
of that story it just you just needed to
see the whole thing yeah was there Mad
Men influence there at all picking up on
that like yeah I mean a little bit yeah
yeah yeah yeah now one thing I was asked
bands like you guys have been together
for so long
one how do you guys deal with conflict
that happens I'll see you you've worked
it out because you're still together
this although like you guys are
real-life couple so how do you separate
all honey to compartmentalize you know
it's a big marriage you know I really
live with each other on the road and we
just try to be mindful of each other and
take care of each other like some of you
work out in your music some of these
songs are very powerful very emotional
like do some people seem to like you
guys okay like just in general you know
we're able to kind of go through all
these different gamuts of emotion is you
know I think we're we're trying to
tackle all the issues in our lives
personally but also musically it's it's
a beautiful experience to try to address
these things right yeah and this album
like you sell produced this album like
where do you guys see yourselves at this
point with us out in your career the
grand scheme of things where you guys
act I think it's the biggest
accomplishment that we've ever had I
mean as a band just to tackle producing
and we've written so many songs we
really could have done a double album we
had so much material and yeah I feel
really proud to kick off of the tour the
tour production the just everything
that's gone into the whole launch the
nightfall at Carnegie Hall and then the
Apollo I mean
it really couldn't have been better and
yeah I'm really proud of us for taking
it on yeah do you guys like before a
show like this Deveney rituals you do
like backstage at Glassman things yes do
we jam we post music we relax we try to
get loose and get ready to just be
ourselves and go do what we've we've
been rehearsed and we know what we're
gonna do so now it's time to let loose
and just let it and come out and we
Circle up right before we go out we put
our ear monitors on everybody gets
geared up and then we circle up and we
literally put our hands on top of each
other we touch each other and our band
and if crew is down in the dressing room
where whoever's there they put their
hands in we say a little prayer and look
at each other and do a little silly
chant that's why I don't want to hold
you back from doing that started